ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนหรอก็
ออกมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนมาหาครูหญิงแล้วก็ครู
ฟ้าในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะในวีดีโอระดับ
บีกินเนอร์คลาสค่ะใช้แล้วเป็นยังไงบ้างคะ
ผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะอะสบายดีครู
ฟ้าราคาเป็นยังไงสบายดีไหมสบายดีค่ะนัก
เรียนสบายดีนะคะนักเรียนสบายดีไหมคะ
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะสบายดีหรือว่าเอาไม่
ค่อยสบายเลยนะก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้แต่ครู
ฟ้าคะวันนี้วันนี้วันกไก่คะ
วันนี้วันที่ออกวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันนี้
วันอังคารวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
อังคารที่ 1
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคม
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศอะไรคะตี
ฮอ
2022 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
จันทร์กับวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 28
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพต.ค
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันพุธค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 2 ค่ะ
เดือนเดือนมีนาคมปีพตต
2565  a คศ 2  022 ค่ะ
วันนี้ก็วันอังคารแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น
10 โมงกี่นาทีคะ
สองนาทีสองนาทีค่ะ
10:02
ก็เป็นเวลากลางอ่าวัน
ชาเป็นตอนกลางวันนะคะข้างๆวันผู้หญิงกิน
ข้าวหรือยังคะผู้หญิงกินข้าวแล้วค่ะครู
ฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยังคะครูฟ้ายังไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวเลย
ขี่อยู่ไหมหิวข้าไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรนะไม่
เป็นไร ok  ok  ok
น้าเดี๋ยว
Video  Set ครูฟ้าก็ไปกินข้าวใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะใช่เพราะว่าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ตอนนี้ใช่ไหมตอนนี้เนี่ยเราสองคนอยู่
ประเทศเดียวกันและผู้หญิงอยู่ประเทศไทย
ครูฟ้า
อยู่ประเทศไทยค่ะตายค่ะเวลาก็ตรงกันนะ
เมื่อฉันไปแล้วดีเนาะดีค่ะเพราะว่าเมื่อ
ก่อนใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่คนละประเทศ
รักครูหญิงอยู่อเมริกาครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศ
ไทยเนาะเวลาเนี่ยไม่ตรงกันเวลา
ห่างกันกี่ชั่วโมง
เวลาห่างการเนี่ย 12 ชั่วโมง
12 ชั่วโมง
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยประเทศไทยแบบ
อยู่ในทวีปเอเชียใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะแล้วอเมริกา
อยู่ในทวีปอะไรคะผู้หญิง
อเมริกาเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ในทวีปเอเชียอยู่
ทวีปอเมริกาเหนือ
อเมริกาเหนือใช่ในโลกของถ้าเราใช่ไหมคะ
อันนี้คือโลกนะคะนักเรียน
โลกก็เข้าสิงทำเป็นอีกมันเป็นแตงโมใช่ไหม
คะ
เหมือนแตงโมเลยค่ะผู้หญิง
สองสาม
เพราะว่าในโลกสมัยขาอันนี้เนาะอันนี้เป็น
โรคน้องโลกก็จะมีเส้นเส้นไม่ใช่แตงโมนะคะ
นักเรียนเข้าไปตรงนี้เนาะเอ่อโลกของเรา
สมัยในโลกของเราเนี่ยก็จะมีทวีปทวีปทวีป
ทวีปเนี่ยถ้าทั้งหมด
กี่ทวีปครูฟ้ารู้มั้ย
เผ็ดไหมคะ
7 ทวีปใช่ค่ะสมัยในโลกเนี่ยมี 7 ทวีปแต่
ว่ามีทวีปอะไรบ้างเดี๋ยวคุณก็คงจะไม่ว่า
โทษทีนะคะที่จะหานี่
ฉันให้นักเรียนดูได้
ทวีปแคระเนื้อต้อง in  Store อีกนะคะไม่
เข้าใจเลย
โอเคไหมคะทุน
แต่ใช้เวลาไม่นานนะคะนักเรียนรอสักครู่
โอเค
มาแล้ว
[เพลง]
ยังไม่ขึ้นยังไม่ขึ้นนะคะเพราะว่ามัน
กำลังเชื่อมต่อน้องกำลัง Connect อยู่อ่ะ
มาแล้วค่ะโล่งนี้ก็คือ
ทวีป
ชายค่ะนี้คือโลกของเราใช่ไหมโลกของเราครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยบอกแล้วว่าในโลกนะคะมีทั้งหมด 7
ทวีป
7 ทวีป 1  2  3  4  5  6  7 ขายค่ะเรา
เอาทวีปของเราก่อนก็เพราะว่าเราอยู่
ประเทศไทยนะคะอ่าทวีปที่ 1 ทวีปอะไรคะครู
ฟ้า
เอเชียค่ะ East  Asia เนาะ a เสียช้าวิธี
ที่ 2 ทวีปอะไรคะ
ยุโรปค่ะใช้ยุโรปทวีปที่ 3 ทวีปอะไรคะ
แอฟริกาค่ะค่ะทวีปที่ 4 ทวีปอะไรคะ
ออสเตรเลีย
ทวีปที่ 5
ทวีปอะไรคะ
อเมริกาเหนือ
ทวีปที่ 6 ทวีปอะไรคะ
อเมริกาใต้ค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ทวีปที่ 7 สมัย
ทวีปสุดท้ายทวีปอะไรคะ
แอนตาร์กติกาน้อง
มีทั้งหมด 7 ทวีปคนไทยเรียนเนาะชายค่ะๆ
แล้วแต่ว่า
งานมาคนก็บอกไม่เหมือนกันใช่ไหมบางคนบอก 4
บางคนบอก 5 มาคนบอก 6
ใช่แต่คนไทยเนี่ยเวลาเรียนนะคะเราบอกว่า
มีทั้งหมด 7 ทวีปใช่ไหมคะครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยประเทศไทยอยู่ทวีปไหนคะ
ครูฟ้าประเทศไทยอยู่ทวีปเอเชียค่ะน้อง
สวิตซ์ที่ 1 ใช่มั้ยทวีปเอเชีย
แล้วนักเรียนนักเรียนอยู่ทวีปอะไรกันบ้าง
ให้คอมเม้นท์บอกแล้ว
นักเรียนคอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะว่าเออนัก
เรียนอยู่ทวีปอะไรใช่ไหมคะแต่ว่าโป้นัก
เรียนรู้จักทวีปแล้วใช่ไหมคะเดี๋ยวเรามา
ฝากอีก 1 รอบแล้วกันเนาะทวีป 1 ทวีปอะไร
คะ
ทวีปเอเชียค่ะทวีปที่ 2 ทวีปอะไรคะทวีป
ยุโรปทวีปที่ 3 ทวีปอะไรคะทวีปแอฟริกา
ทวีปที่ 4 ทวีปอะไรคะทวีปออสเตรเลียทวีป
ที่ 5 ทวีปอะไรคะ
อเมริกาเหนือทวีปที่ 6 ทวีปอะไรคะ
ทวีปอเมริกาใต้ค่ะแล้วก็ทวีปที่ 7 ทวีป
อะไรคะ
แอนตาร์กติกาค่ะจะโอเคนักเรียนรู้จักทวีป
แล้วเดี๋ยวเราจะมาเช็คว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยรู้
ไหมว่า
ประเทศอะไรอยู่ทวีปอะไรจะครูหญิงน่ะนะคะ
จะพูดชื่อปเพียงเพศสวยงานแล้วครูฟ้าก็จะ
บอกว่าอยู่ทวีปอะไร
หนู
[เพลง]
หญิงยากไร้นักเรียนยากไหมนั่นสิผู้หญิงก็
ต้องรู้ใช่ไหมอีกก็ต้องรู้นะ
โอ้เป็นกี้แห้งสาวสุภตื่นเต้นนะคิดถึง
เปลี่ยนสายๆ
อารักประเทศ
สวีเดนณประเทศสวีเดนอยู่ทวีปอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ร้านเฮดสวีเดน
ยุโรปค่ะถ้าซื้อที่ 2 ใช่ไหมทวีปยุโรปของ
ยุโรปฮาโอเคเก่งมากต่อไปนะคะ
ประเทศ
บราซิล
ประเทศบราซิล
The  Mask ฟิว
บราซิลเนาะบราซิลก็จะมีแบบแซมบ้าและ
ฟุตบอลเก่งซึ่งไหมประเทศบราซิลอยู่ทวีป
อะไร
ประเทศบราซิลอยู่ทวีป
อเมริกาใต้ค่ะหนังสือที่ 6  size ทวีป
อเมริกาใต้
เก่งมากค่ะต่อไปนะคะ
ประเทศ
ญี่ปุ่น
นางประเทศญี่ปุ่นครูฟ้ายังอยู่ไหมคะคือ
ว่ากูหญิงอินเตอร์เน็ตค้างค่ะ
โอเคกลับมาแล้วก็ผู้หญิงนะคะอินเตอร์เน็ต
ผู้หญิงไม่ค่อยโอเคน้องอ่ะประเทศญี่ปุ่น
ญี่ปุ่นนะคะประเทศญี่ปุ่นอยู่ทวีปอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้า
ประเทศญี่ปุ่น
ที่อยู่ทวีป
เอเชียค่ะเอเชียเสียงเนาะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะ
ประเทศเคนยาโห
เคนยาลำเคนย่าค่ะกินอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมประเทศ
เคนย่านะคะอยู่ทวีปอะไรคะครูฟ้าอยู่ทวีป
แอฟริกาค่ะโอ๋
ฟานี่เก่งเหมือนกันนะประเทศนิวซีแลนด์
ประเทศนิวซีแลนด์
อยู่ทวีปอะไรคะครูฟ้า
นิวซีแลนด์
อยู่ทวีป
ออสเตรเลียมั้ยไม่ชัวร์ใช่ๆๆๆทวีป
ออสเตรเลียถูกแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวเสียง
ประเทศแคนาดาประเทศแคนาดาที่อยู่ทวีปอะไร
คะครูฟ้า
ประเทศแคนาดาอยู่ทวีป
นิสัยอ่ะอยู่ไหนอ่ะยะลา
อเมริกาไหนครูบาสกูฟ้าคิดว่าแคนาดาอยู่
ตรงไหนแคนาดาอยู่
ใกล้ๆอเมริกานะใส่สาย
อเมริกาหนึ่งนักเรียน
ใช่ค่ะอยู่ที่ 5 ใช่ไหมทวีปอเมริกาเหนือ
ประเทศ
ชิลีความรู้จักชิลีไหมปีเขียนถูกมั้ย
เนี่ย
มิลี่เขยประเทศชิลีอยู่ทวีปอะไรคะครูฟ้า
แม่ใช่ยุโรปมะอเมริกาเหนือค่ะบริการเหนือ
ริกาเหนือ
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ชื่อ
Siri หรอคะ
เอา
[เพลง]
อเมริกาได้ Away ริกาใต้ใช่ค่ะประเทศชิลี
อยู่อเมริกาใต้เนาะเจาะครูบาก็เก่งนะรู้
จักว่าหลายๆประเทศอยู่ทวีปอะไร
ล์หาผู้หญิงมีอีกแล้วโอเค
ประเทศ
อังกฤษ
ประเทศอังกฤษอังกฤษไปนักเรียนจะบอกว่า
อะไรคือประเทศอังกฤษนะคะประเทศอังกฤษแค่
เรียนกลไทยเรียกอังกฤษเนอะประเทศอังกฤษ
อยู่ทวีปอะไรคะ
ประเทศอังกฤษอยู่ทวีปยุโรปค่ะแฮเก่งว่า
ค่ะ
ประเทศลิเบียๆและ
ลิเบีย
เคยได้ยิน
ประเทศลิเบีย
ลิเบียอยู่ทวีปอะไรคะ
อะไรอ่ะอเมริกาใต้หรอไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่อเมริกา
ใต้ไม่ใช่กูฟ้าวบอกอันนี้ใช่ไหมอเมริกา
ใต้ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
อเมริกาเหนืออเมริกาเหนืออันนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
ใบทรายค่ะ
ยุโรปโหลคิดชายสัตว์แอฟริกา
แอฟริกา
ชัยค่ะ
เย้ในที่สุดครูฟ้าก็รู้คุยก็ต้องนั่งหานะ
เพื่อความแน่ใจ
RE เสียวๆทั่วประเทศ
อินเดียประเทศอินเดียอยู่ทวีปอะไรนะครู
ฟ้าประเทศอินเดียอยู่ทวีปเอเชียทั้งบน
เก่งว่าค่ะแต่ครูฟ้าเราก็พูดมาหลายๆ
ประเทศใช่ไหมคะมีทั้งในทวีปเอเชียทวีป
ยุโรปทวีปแอฟริกาทวีปออสเตรเลียทวีป
อเมริกาเหนือทวีปอเมริกาใต้แต่ทวีป
แอนตาร์กติกา
ไม่มีประเทศ
อ่ะ
แอนตาร์กติกามีประเทศอะไรเวลานักเรียนนี่
ไหมนักเรียนก็บอกเราได้นะเราก็ไม่ค่อย
เก่ง Geographic นะครับภูมิศาสตร์เท่า
ไหร่มีเพนกวินนะไป
ทวีปแอนตาร์กติกาและมีเพนกวินใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวพี่จะวาดเป็นปีนะคะหวีไหมฮ่าๆๆนี่
เป็นกรินเนื้อเห็น quinn เหมือนเว้ย
อีกแล้วพิณพิณเหรอฝาใช่ไหมค่ะทวีป
แอนตาร์กติกาเชื่อไหมมีเพนกวินหรออ่ะใน
โลกเนี่ยนะคะมี 7 ประเทศเนี่ยเราไม่ใช่มี
เศษประเทศขอโทษถามมี 7 ทวีปใช่ไหมคะแล้ว
ก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็รู้แล้วว่าก็แต่ละทวีปมี
ประเทศอะไรบ้าง
ไฟฟ้าเนาะครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดว่าถ้า 1 วันนะ
ครูฟ้ามีเงินใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เป็นเงินมากๆที่รหัสผู้หญิงเงินสะอาด
1 ล้านบาทแล้วก็น่าจะพอเที่ยวนะคะ 1
ล้านบาทมีเงิน 1 ล้านบาทใช่ไหมมีเงินแล้ว
ก็ครูฟ้าก็มีเวลามีเวลาเนาะอาจจะเบรคไม่
ทำงาน
ถ้าวัน
ไหนฟ้ามีเงินมีเวลาเนาะคู่ฟ้าคิดอยากจะไป
ทวีปอะไรอยากจะไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมหูฟ้าก็อาจ
จะนั่งเครื่องบินนั่งเครื่องบินแล้วก็ไป
เที่ยวซะนั้นไปดูไปถ่ายรูปไปกินอาหาร
ครูขาอยากไปทวีปอะไรมากที่สุดก็คุณให้ 2
ทวีปฟ้าเลือกมา 2 ทวีป
ทวีปยุโรปค่ะครูฟ้าบอกวันนี้เลยใช่ไหม
ทวีปยุโรปโรคค่ะยุโรปอ่ะ
ทวีปอะไร
ทวีป
อะไรดีนะเอาอเมริกาเหนือคือว่าว่าอะไรที่
2 ทวีปอเมริกาเหนือขอราคาเออ
อยากไปทวีปยุโรปอ่ะ
หนึ่งแล้วก็ 2 ทวีปอเมริกาเหนือ
อายใน 2 ทวีปแล้วครูหญิงนะคะผู้หญิงถ้า
ครูหญิงมีเงิน
หนึ่งล้านดอลลาร์
xxx
ผู้หญิงดี 1 ล้าน
US ดอลลาร์ใช่ไหมคะก็ได้ 1 ล้าน US
1 ล้านสั่ง
ผู้หญิงจะไปที่ไหนคะทวีปอะไร
2 ทวีปใช่ไหม 2 ผ่าถ้าครูหญิงหน้านะคะ
ผู้หญิงจะไป 1 ทวีปออสเตรเลีย
Australia  are  you ม 2 อ่ะสองก็เหมือน
ครูฟ้านะคะคุณอยากไปทวีปยุโรปสมัยทวีป
ยุโรปใส่ไหนอยากไป 2 ทวีปนะคะจึงถูกเพราะ
อยากไปแอนตาร์กติกาเหมือนกันนะ
คะมี 3 เนาะก็บอกว่าเออทวีปแอนตาร์กติกา
ก็โอเคนะไปดูเพนกวินไปดูเพนกวิน
ดูเห็นกรีซนะแล้วก็แล้วนักเรียนเหรอคะนัก
เรียนอยากไปทวีปอะไรใช่ไหมนักเรียนจะไป
ทวีปอะไรน้องก็จะมีหนึ่งทวีปอะไรนะคะ
เอเชีย
ยุโรป
แอฟริกา 4
ออสเตรเลียถ้า
อเมริกาเหนือ 6 อเมริกาใต้ 7
อันศักดิ์สิก้าไก่ค่ะก็มีทั้งหมด 7 ทวีป
เนาะนักเรียนอยากไปทวีปอะไรก็คอมเม้นบอก
เราได้นะคะส่วนนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนเนาะ
แล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ